[Music]
hey
everybody
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
hello hello something about pookie we do
understand yeah good afternoon is it me
or the audio way off i wonder why
what happened what about the uh oh look
i saw something it looked like it was
off
but go back to that other page
it's red it says off what is that that's
the webcam i can't see it
that's that's just that right that's
that's fine um
now it's okay the other saying is okay
now okay yeah i wonder what that was all
about
maybe it was just lag could be i did
have to restart this [ __ ] because it was
like [ __ ] like right before yeah
yeah so i don't know if you guys heard
what we said but yeah we were talking
about i i talked about accidentally
kicking pookie this morning because she
like ran under my legs like she was all
excited
to see me in the closet and i didn't see
her because it was kind of dark
and then she got pissed off but yeah so
uh and she was in here but she ran away
because she was like [ __ ] you guys
you're not talking to me you're talking
to the lights again
but yeah so today we're talking about i
want to say something how many of you
guys went and saw a blood vessel
last night after we reviewed it we'll go
ahead yeah probably a lot of people did
yeah
that was a really good morning i did
some more studying on the stragoi
yeah oh yeah that's right you told me
about that yeah the stragoi
is not a copy of a vampire bram stroker
stroker that's a stroke that's a that's
porn versus a [ __ ]
brand stoker he uh
read stories of the stragoi and from
that
he made that vampire story yeah i mean
bram stoker like before he wrote dracula
he did like all the vampire research
like he went all
into like the they had up here and
things like that too
which was like a vampire but he got it
he got it from romanians trigloid
yeah and it did a lot of the things that
it the the [ __ ] that i saw it do in in
in
in um blood vessel
that's actually how it's described and
not in in the in the legends
and what i thought was cool about it is
that you had living stragoi
and then you had undead stragoi yeah you
could be a strago
and be alive and then when you died you
came back as an undead
so it was kind of a win-win and here's
the even weirder [ __ ] thing about a
struggle
astragoy living or dead could interbreed
with the living the undead and the dead
that is a true pansexual that's a
[ __ ] yeah
evidently a stragoi i guess an undead
could mate with a dead person and make a
living child from that that's quite a
trick
yeah i don't know how that happens but
they were worried about it
that's how it happened now how they all
looked different they all had and it
says that undead struggle
had animalistic features like rats and
[ __ ] bats and [ __ ] like that in
wolves
but remember how when he went to his
wife she didn't come out of the grave
he gave her some blood and she came out
yeah so she might have been turned into
a struggle from a dead body
you see the dead back to life
yeah just very different than biting
somebody and making them a struggle
yeah so there was all kinds of weird
mixtures they had families
and the families had a mixture of the
living
the dead and the undead were all in the
damn
or the revived dead and then the undead
and they're all they were all
in relationships with each other
marrying people and having children
that's just a weird concept that's even
better yeah than the [ __ ] vampire
everybody is recommending the uh
guillermo del toro series the strain
which was also about a strawberry
okay yeah so i had heard about that a
few years ago but i haven't seen it yet
because i love guillaume del toro yeah i
don't know if
he'd write or produce it i can't
remember they could command swarms of
[ __ ] animals and
insects which you see that a lot in
dracula movies
yeah and command and swarms and stuff
but they did that struggle i did that
too
i wish i could just kind of kind of
interesting swarms of stuff
yeah that would be kind of neat but yeah
so the movie we're talking about today
uh is actually a new one it's from 2020
that just came out on netflix
this is a polish slasher of all things
i read i don't know if this is true or
not maybe if anyone is from poland they
can tell me
this is supposedly like the first polish
produced
slasher maybe not the first polish
horror movie obviously but the first
you know traditional slasher type movie
and it's called nobody sleeps in the
woods tonight i am not going to attempt
to pronounce
the polish title so this was directed by
bartosz kowalski hi pokey she's back
again
what's up pokey pants and basically
what you got is you have your standard
slasher setup
you got like all these teenagers that
are like various types you got like
the kind of cute quiet girl you got like
the chubby nerdy kid
you got like the hot girl uh the dude
that runs around with a shirt off all
the time
kind of the sensitive gay man you have
so you have all these kids and they go
to this camp that's like out in like the
remote
you know ass end of nowhere of poland
and
the funny thing and i kind of like that
they did this as a setup the camp is
called
adrenaline like yeah and it's for
kids that are addicted to their
technology
like to their cell phones and stuff so
that's one of the things that you have
to do when you stay at this camp it's
like a three-day camp
and you have to give up all of your
devices hence nobody really has one
when they're all out in the woods and
[ __ ] starts to go sideways
so it's the interesting thing about this
it's almost kind of like
you know yeah there's a lot of you know
friday the 13th kind of set up
it's almost going a little bit in a
comedy like or a little bit of a meta
direction it's not zany or anything but
there's a little bit of a scream
influence where like you know this
little chubby nerdy kid is like into
horror movies and he's just like oh we
can't do this because the bad [ __ ]
happens in horror movies and everyone
just does it anyway and
then gets killed horribly but one thing
i like about this movie is that
i guess the um the monster in it
or the killer which are actually killers
because it's actually two guys
but um it's kind of like has a little
bit of a sci-fi but also kind of like a
mutant kind of [ __ ]
because they kind of do us they kind of
do like a um flashback and tell you
because the monster when you see them
they're like these big dude kind of
looks like the toxic avenger
a little bit like this big round you got
like boils and [ __ ] all over them around
looking bloated dudes
you know and i'm just sitting there
going what the [ __ ] is that thing
because like for a while i didn't know
if like the monster was going to be just
like a regular guy if it was going to be
like a
like a werewolf or i didn't really know
so when they
actually showed the dude and he's just
like this big
like i said he reminds me the toxic
avenger but like much much larger
you know what i mean he's you know he's
just like this big dude with boils all
over him
and you find out later on that i guess
these were two
twins who when they were kids they found
like a meteor
like a green meteor like in their
backyard and the first day i was like
meteor [ __ ]
you know what i mean like creep show but
um i thought it was an homage to creep
show actually
i think it probably was because there
was a lot of homage oh definitely stuff
in it oh definitely
and uh that was what like mutated them
and turned them into these things
and then i guess like their mom you know
they're like well they're still my
babies even though they're monsters so
she like kept them down in the cellar
like feeding them because she didn't
want anybody to know that they were in
there
and uh i guess every now and then they
bust out and like start killing some
people
and that's what ends up happening in
this movie um
so yeah what did you think of this movie
tom it was okay
i liked it i think it was pretty good
for a slasher yeah yeah it was um
it i gotta say you know it's better than
a lot of the [ __ ] hollywood [ __ ]
that's come out
i think you know what i mean it's um
it's i would call it a traditional
horror slasher movie wasn't any flim
flam in it a lot of homages
it had that same tone as kind of like
kind of like a cross between friday the
first friday the 13th and
halloween and just maybe scream or
something yeah it had like a little bit
of a meta kind of
screen type of thing yeah it had
elements of comedy and it had right
mixer comedy and
sexuality and horror i guess you know
and action
because they they did a lot of stuff
that you know
american slashing movies did and they
they talk about it and met you know they
talk about
they talk about slash movies in the
movie yeah okay
if you had sex or getting it on you're
gonna get killed somebody's gonna get
killed
um it just had all there
you know smoking weed is a meme in it
just everything
everything the movie did was just kind
of like along that genre it fulfilled
all the elements of a slasher genre yeah
it was like wings on purpose
it was like winking at you but not in a
really obnoxious
straightforward way could have been a
little bit funnier
um because i feel well but that might
have been lost in the translation i kind
of feel like because
the humor in it seemed a little dry
but i don't know if that was just
because like you know i don't speak
polish obviously so it's like maybe it
was just kind of
they just knew what they were doing and
they knew who you were as an audience
member they knew who was what they're
like hey you want to see some titties
there they are they are yeah you want to
see some sex here it is
you want to see like a whole bunch of
gore here you go here's what here's a
wood chipper you know what's next
they already know they're already
telling you you know what i mean
the wood chipper that's kind of because
i was thinking oh that was a tucker and
nail versus evil moment wasn't it
because i was like oh i hope someone's
going in there there is a lot of there
is a lot of [ __ ] evil dead
uh kind of references to it not really
references but
homage is in it too from some of the
action scenes
from what i remember yeah you know like
the
the wood chipper scene was kind of like
kind of like
uh what what was that friday the 13th
four or three
yeah they had the wood chippers like a
mixture of that and something out of the
evil dead
and there was also a direct uh homage to
friday the 13th part seven
the infamous sleeping bag kill yeah
where jason picks up the person the
sleepy
just like slams him against a tree
that's why he did that
they did that in this one too yeah
that's uh because you see when i saw
jason do that
for me it was homagin prophecy
see i don't i can't remember i saw that
one first movie yeah
probably wasn't that that was a big
meeting big mutant bear
and it [ __ ] ran into somebody's
campsite they were hiding from it and
hiding from it in the in the in the
sleeping bag
threw it against the [ __ ] well see
now i need to see prophecy again because
i saw that all the feathers went
when did that come out 76 77 something
like that scared the [ __ ] out of me when
i was like i was 78.
yeah i remember seeing it when i was a
kid but i don't remember much about it
so when i
so it could be it happened at a time
when
on the news there was always this scare
about well the first was a scary about
ketone
that was the first maybe keto sort of
vaguely they were just
trying to tell everybody how poisonous
ketone was i think ketones had food now
but anyway uh there was a ketone scare
and then there's a uh
there was a mercury scare about them i
remember that mercury's
the mercury in the water yeah mercury in
the water was
mutating the frogs it was kind of like
the old version of [ __ ]
turning the frogs gay it was like it was
going out of control
and that's what that that's what the
prophecy was about mutant excuse me
mercury in the water this is based on
memory i haven't seen this [ __ ] in
forever people so if i'm wrong you know
i think that that's what it was mercury
in the water
got into some fish and the bear and a
pregnant bear ate the fish
yeah yeah yeah and then that's what
happened yeah and then
and then she had like she had a mutant
bear it was huge
yet i think babies might have eaten each
other i don't remember it it's been a
long time
but one of them tom's vague movie
is moving from retrospective when
they're this i was a little kid
[ __ ] with the dude with the shirt the
dude in the arm and the bear
and what came out of it was a big old
house
yeah do the whole thing like that i need
to do my own i need to be funny as hell
i need to do my own little show in here
it's just me going and then the dude did
this and that happened
anyway what came out of this [ __ ] was a
[ __ ]
gigantic bald mutant bear that was
albino and had it
one one side of its face was all [ __ ]
up walked around on two legs
almost like a man and uh
back in the day it was [ __ ] scary i
think it had little bitty arms or hands
i don't remember exactly how it looked
looked like a mutant bear it was
standing up tyrannosaurus rex arms
yeah yeah i think it did i don't
remember what it was weird
it looked out of proportion when they
finally showed it towards the end when
they would show the whole thing at once
it didn't it didn't look the proportions
didn't look right
yeah yeah i mean you could tell it was
mechanical now i need to see that again
we need to like
throw that into the ring to do the
prophecy because i remember seeing it
because it was like in the 70s it was
like a whole slate of like environmental
horror where like animals
go berserk you know what i mean was it
called prophecy yeah
prophecy yeah well no there's one called
the prophecy that had christopher walken
in it that was
that was completely different that was
like more religious
i remember that that was actually pretty
good yeah yeah it was just called
prophecy
yeah this one was just called private
and i'm pretty sure it was 70
eight it was in the mid to late 70s i
think it was 1970 it was around the same
time as alien one when it came out
but alien one blew it away but i
remember like in
fangoria magazine you know what i mean
you saw clips from yeah you just see the
stills
the stills from this bear and then [ __ ]
from alien and then you know
[ __ ] from saturn saturn five also you
know the damn robot
yeah from standard five it's all run
that same era
yeah but yeah like i said i was i there
was a whole bunch of these kind of
movies like i love
i still love the swarm and uh kingdom of
the spiders yeah that had [ __ ] chat
in it yeah the shot
the shaft cause tarantulas i know that
was so good
it was so good it's like uh empire of
the ants
yeah you had all the food of the gods
yeah man i loved those [ __ ] movies
and i was going to orca
when you were a kid they were awesome i
know i love all those cheap and [ __ ]
well they're cheesy as [ __ ] but it's
like i really enjoy i really liked like
killer animals run amok movies like when
i was growing up i was like super into
that
entertaining oh man my battery went out
i've been having problems
charging this [ __ ] well didn't i give
you that charger i didn't work
that other cord that i gave you did
actually work on my [ __ ] so i don't know
what the hell is wrong with you
um fourth throw down says were there
boobs in it were there boobs in which
movie
which what there were boobs in this
movie that we're talking about
that but prophecy i don't know if there
was i don't know if there was boobs in
it i don't remember it's been so long
ago since i've seen it
now i got to look it up though [ __ ] was
not going to write this down because uh
yeah that was one movie i remember that
um stephen king talked about it in dance
macabre
like he was kind of going on and out
about how cheesy that was because he was
talking about that and he was talking
about amd evil horror and he was kind of
talking about all those movies that came
out around that
uh time period but yeah so this one like
i said it's
it's um if you like slasher movies i'm
sure you probably
will enjoy it it's very it's a pretty
standard slasher movie like i said it
had kind of an original
backstory like to the monsters and i
liked that they were just kind of like
these big
mutants like covered in boils and it had
like a little bit of a
meteor type [ __ ] going on with it so it
had like a little bit of a sci-fi thing
but other than that you know it was
pretty good phase four somebody said yes
that was uh also very good actually
phase four
i think was i mean
probably like quality wise was like the
best of all those because as much as i
love
you know the swarm with those terrible
bees that were like all [ __ ]
i'm done with mats and stuff and like
the the cheesy [ __ ] the
the best thing about those movies is
that you had like all these
i hate to call them has beens because
that seems very judgmental
but it's always kind of like people
who's just like elizabeth taylor and
it's like people whose better days were
behind them yeah they
ended up being in the ceiling kind of
basically
like one step up from made for tv movies
that had like
you know getting chased around by
[ __ ] spiders and giant rabbits and
whatnot
night of the leapus i also kind of love
knight of the leapus too
although it's hard to make giant bunnies
scary
but you know humanoids from the deep
yeah
we just watched that one not too long
ago because i think that might be on
shutter or
something like that what are you doing
down there pookie she's chewing on stuff
she's chewing on the stop biting the
furniture
she's like a tiny goat she just wants to
always chew on everything
all right so is there you on metal i
don't understand that
i know are you chewing on metal yeah
she's really into it the pookie panther
chewing on metal it must feel good on
the teeth
i guess so feels good because for a
while like i was worried about it
because i thought maybe i was like well
maybe she's got like something wrong
with her gums and it's like she's like
teething or something but i looked at
her gums and they don't look red or like
anything like that that's biting on
stuff
oracle says pookie is practicing
fighting mutant monsters yeah that's
what it is yeah she's getting ready for
like the robot overlords she's gonna
like fight against she's just gonna like
keep fighting them and [ __ ]
yeah so this one was okay it was it's
good i liked it yeah
it was a way above average let's put it
that way yeah i'd probably give it you
know like
for the type of movie that it is four
out of five stars probably
yeah i mean you know nice cinematography
it's like you know entertaining had a
lot of good gore in it
yeah um you know good monsters like i
said i liked
like the big lumbering yeah mutant dudes
that was like pretty cool i think i
liked blood vessel better though
uh well yeah i'm gonna say i did like
blood vessel a lot better but different
kind of movie but yeah this
yeah it's hard to compare compare them
right you know one horror movie another
because especially it's like a totally
different sub genre so it's like
you know the different subgenres have
different blood vessel almost kind of
reminded me of a
little bit of a lower budget version of
underworld not quite as flashy as
remember underworld
yeah with the girl or something like out
of blade
yeah blade one or two but not quite not
as big budget though
those are pretty good movies i like it
yeah louis says you guys need a rating
system
i thought about doing that like i first
started doing when i first started doing
my book reviews i kind of
did like stars and then i was like man
[ __ ] it it's like it's too hard to like
come up with
you know what i mean yeah and it's just
like there's so many
it just seems really reductive and
honestly i just don't really like to do
it
pat hatfield says watch a double feature
of night of the leapus and frogs
if you want to overdo some stupidity
yeah if i remember i vaguely remember
frogs i need to see that again too
how about squirm yeah remember that
about the worms coming up out of the
ground biting people
i've seen that one like lots of times
because it was on mystery science
theater so i always watched that whole
episode
in a sea of worms that he was you gonna
be the worm face
that [ __ ] guy what you doing stop
turning [ __ ] up oh my goodness
she's tearing stuff up all right so we
better like entertain her before she
like eats everything
in this she's like you guys are talking
to the lights again stop talking to the
lights come talk to pokey yeah
she's gonna eat all your [ __ ] yes all
right so uh we will be back tomorrow
talking about another movie i got one
picked out might not be a brand new one
but it's just a couple of years old
and then i'm gonna watch later so uh
thanks everybody for stopping by on this
monday
and we will see you guys again tomorrow
bye